salut tout le monde ce crime fléchettes
à flipper que faire quand on a pas
d'inspiration les amis c'est
habituellement moi qui vous fait rire
j'espère aujourd'hui on a inversé les
rôles tout en faisant la moulinette et
c'est vous qui allez me faire marrer
j'ai demandé sur twitter n'est pas une
petite vidéo pour me faire marrer je
vais les regarder avec vous ça va
s'appeler la vidéo facile hockey
commence avec ian au [ __ ] merci à nos
des rares pense à moi je te mets au défi
de me battre celui qui reste le plus
longtemps sans cligner des yeux tu es
prêt 1 2
aa je suis nul ou bat ce jeu un jeu
chiale ça va tuer les yeux tu vas crever
c'est pas moi qui ait acheté le produit
à l'anti pour s'hydrater les yeux
derrière à temps mais ça on pousse des
vidéos à tanger le temps de refaire le
challenge est de reperdre avant lui a
certainement des vidéos courtes mais bon
là je tiens mes bêtes mais c'est pas un
problème c'est que je chiale tu m'as
fait chialer
je pense que tu as clean et je pense que
je peux non at a perdu yana abonnez vous
un double double slash user 7 h 23
ayad tu m'as fait pleurer devant mes
abonnés j'ai appelé cette vidéo je
pleure devant mes abonnés merci grâce à
toi je suis le titre et la miniature moi
je faisais la pause pour la vie nature
je vous enflammez pas j'ai dû arrêter
avant mon record 3 minutes 12
le mec ce chronomètre quoi qu on en est
là poursuivant mdr c'est très mal les on
aime c'est très très bien raison voilà
qu'est ce que c'est que ça il ya un
chapelet on en est là monsieur monsieur
allison on en est là encore un chat mais
arrêtez de vous chers plus tôt
[Musique]
non maintenant mais ça c'est vilain n'ai
jamais cassé son chat après ça jamais
retient ashton karba tu fais pas chien
chat c'est quoi ça qu'est ce que c'est
que ça ce que tu fais si c'est quoi
il revient mais pourquoi je sais pas
demander d'ouvrir le fromage sur un sur
un taux unique et hors essence épicé
c'est simple efficace très bien je
m'abonne je vais essayer faire crier ma
maman voilà mais moi je suis ta mère
garçons mais je viens j'ai beau avoir un
corps de nos déplacements
bla bla ça c'est pour faire exprès de
faire crier [ __ ] avec ma mère amour et
même mère mourir décapité pas fait ça ok
suivant aux 250 r tu es et tu sais
qu'aujourd'hui fois c'est l'anniversaire
du mimi mathy et tu sais quel âge à
aujourd'hui la 50e en bref on s'en fout
un peu tu vois là bas on n'a pas vu
grandir des grosses barres
mr et mme b qui nous fait une vidéo [ __ ]
a continué à liker et abonnez vous
toujours de bon conseil si mr et mme d
ouais ok celui dont le beau-frère de
sagua j'adore les chutes comme ça ou en
douceur bien finesse c'est gentil de
tomber pour moi et je parle pas de la
prison aaa énorme qui s'il a fait super
kiwi du mois marqués squeeze tué
inspectent tu es très très fort en
informatique tu changes tu vas marquer
un truc mature je suppose oui
et maintenant tu as route
ouais bravo à toi j'ai reçu un sms en
même temps la chaîne youtube a été banni
pour avoir diffusé un vine aussi pour yb
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça l'a
fait à vos animaux quand cette famille
est venue me chercher dans mon élevage à
côté de mes frères et soeurs
j'étais heureux je voulais vivre avec
eux mais en réalité chaque jour je dois
dansé pendant plus de 10 minutes pour
divertir mais m sais-tu faire ça
ah le botteur ou adolf lipton jamais
essayé j'aime essayer mais qui attention
on va rétablir la vérité
ces premiers ma vie mon point de vue
jamais fait ça de ma vie à toi je peux
te regarder aux [ __ ] c'est super
marrant à faire j'ai vu ça de ma vie
voilà je préfère l'amour aller ok on
passe à la suite fait une meilleure
tonne life que moi ses cousins de poser
un regard sur cette table vieux truc
flag et vaughan la pause est le plus
petit truc du monde quoi tu es une carte
sd avec certains cas mais pas trop quand
ta soeur adore jouer
comment percer sur youtube astuces sur
vidéo tu fais bien de le dire coucou les
copains bienvenue pour une nouvelle
vidéo et comme vous avez pu le voir dans
le titre je vais vous apprendre à percer
sur youtube je sais pas quoi dire
est ce qu'on n'est pas au niveau 1 du
jeu de mots là à non non non c'est fait
non tu perds s'arrête at a maintenant
plus d'abonnés qu'avec cet arrêt times
un doublé n'est ce pas le visage d'un
homme fier de sa blague
ici c'est la première fois que je
réussis dont ce rire de merde non
attends t'es bon c'est quoi ça non à
makemo chapter et qu'une poubelle c'est
jamais bon goût
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
pourquoi me défier vous avec votre
challenge de merde je me prends pour
david lafarge
j'ai foiré mon challenge mais vous avez
réussi mais fait rire ça m'a fait du
bien à trouver dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien john
[Musique]